>> So, I just wanted to thank everyone for
coming.
And also, I'd like to welcome Kate Roberts
to Google.
Kate is the Founder and Director of YouthAIDS
and Five & Alive, two marketing programs implemented
by the Population Services International (PSI),
where she is a Vice President of Corporate
Marketing and Communications.
Founded in 2001, YouthAIDS is a global education
and prevention initiative that uses media,
pop culture, music, theatre and sport to stop
the spread of HIV/AIDS and reach 600 million
young people in more than 60 countries with
life-saving messages, products, services and
care.
In 2002 YouthAIDS partnered with MTV to produce
the "Staying Alive" concert, a $3 million
production broadcast worldwide and featured
on all major news channels, including CNN.
Other noted productions include an innovative,
celebrity-driven, cause-related marketing
campaign -- Hear No Evil, See No Evil, Speak
No Evil -- through a partnership with ALDO
Shoes and four award-winning documentaries
aired on VH1, The Discovery Channel and National
Geographic aimed at raising awareness about
the global HIV/AIDS crisis as they follow
YouthAIDS Global Ambassador Ashley Judd through
the most affected areas of Africa, Central
America and India.
Roberts has been featured in the Washington
Post, named “Power Player of the Week”
by Fox News, and celebrated on “CNN Heroes.”
Kate has also been given the honor of speaking
at the Aspen Ideas Festival and has recently
been awarded “Young Global Leader of the
World 2007” by The World Economic Forum.
Most recently, Roberts has launched Five & Alive,
an exciting new marketing initiative aimed
at raising funds and awareness for PSI’s
child survival programs, and has co-founded
the Global India Fund.
Originally from England, Kate holds a degree
in Hotel and Catering Management from Southport
University of Art and Technology.
And lastly, we'll be filming this for YouTube.
So during the Q and A, please make sure to
use one of the microphones.
Thanks so much, Kate, for coming.
Kate Roberts: Thank you.
I realize I'm competing with Octoberfest,
so I really appreciate you guys being here.
So yeah. I'm Kate Roberts, and I founded YouthAIDS
about ten years ago.
And what I've decided to do today is try to
tell you the story of building this brand.
I don't know if you are marketeers and that's
what you want to hear, but I figured by telling
my story, it might really highlight in a different
way how we actually do development differently.
In fact, I was telling Laura over lunch that
I'm reading a book right now called "Fred.”
And it's all about a guy who's a postman.
And it's all about his passion that he's turned
his life around even though he's a postman.
But he found a passion in his life that made
an ordinary life very, very exciting.
And I think that I can say that about myself.
I have a very, very ordinary life -- or at
least had a very ordinary life -- and now
my life is very, very interesting and exciting.
So I'm here to tell that story.
I am technically challenged, so I really apologize
for anything that goes wrong with this presentation.
Well, first of all, my journey to do this
work started with a bet.
And I'm going to get into why that was, but
first of all to give you a little bit of background
on what I used to do.
I was in advertising for many, many years
working for Saatchi & Saatchi, an advertising
agency in Eastern Europe.
I lived pretty much all over the world.
I grew up on a ship.
My father's a sea captain.
So I spent my early years traveling around
the world exploring different cultures and
religions and seeing a lot of poverty along
the way, but decided to go into for-profit
work working in advertising, which took me
to Eastern Europe.
I went to live in Russia.
I headed up the Eastern European operations,
and had a number of big adventures.
Had a run-in with the Russian Mafia, and both
being kidnapped several times and having adventures
in Russia led me to have to escape the country.
So I fled from Russia about 13 years ago,
and found my way to Romania to again work
for Saatchi & Saatchi.
And my focus was cigarettes and alcohol and
bubble gum, and all things that kids really
liked.
And it was my job to come up with strategies
of how to get them to smoke more cigarettes
and eat more bubble gum and drink more soda
pop and whiskey and all the things that were
destroying their health.
And I have to tell you that I didn't really
have a problem with that.
And I was kind of good at it.
And I had the first-class-ticket lifestyle
where I was able to travel all over the world
and buy nice clothes and buy nice shoes.
And I had a shoe passion -- very expensive
one.
And I was going along my merry way in Romania.
Actually, I don't know whether you know much
about Romania, but it's a very small country,
used to be Communist, and what struck me about
the country was, it was a very passionate
country, but there was very little resources
for youth.
There was no real parties or action or color
or fashion.
And what I decided to do in Romania was to
tap into my world of pop culture and bring
that to my for-profit clients who were paying
me a lot of money to do their marketing.
So, along my way of doing these outrageous
promotions, I was approached by a very innovative
and impressive man, Michael Holscher, who
was representing an organization called PSI,
Population Services International, for Romania.
And he'd read about me in the media of doing
these rave parties and cigarette campaigns
and working for Coca-Cola and various different
brands.
And he simply asked me if I would lend my
time to helping him develop the first AIDS
campaign in Romania.
And immediately, I thought to myself, "Hmm.
Well, this might be interesting.
Maybe this will lead to some award of some
sort.”
And certainly didn't think at the time how
this could serve the population of Romania
well.
And we went on -- I agreed -- and the issue
was that PSI Romania didn't have a lot of
funds to develop the campaign.
So I looked into what I was doing with my
for-profit clients, and thought, "I could
go to those different companies to get the
resources necessary to launch this campaign.”
So we came across an idea called, "In Bed
with You.”
And we had this big, red, shiny bed that would
travel around to different places to really
get the issue of HIV out there.
And we would invite various rock stars and
musicians and actors and actresses to get
into bed with young people to talk about their
first sexual experience and all the issues
that face young people around reproductive
health and their first sexual encounters and
safe sex.
So we developed this campaign, "In Bed with
You," and we were really able to harness the
resources that were in Romania -- we actually
had the launch party in a brothel.
And which, of course, was very risky in those
times, but we were able to bring in all the
big TV stations, all the different media outlets.
And we launched one of the first condoms in
Romania.
And, within a year, we had managed to increase
condom use by a hundred percent.
So I got the bug.
And we were really looking at different innovative
ways of delivering this message and getting
these condoms into the hands of people who
needed them the most.
And, of course, it was exhausting.
I became quite obsessed with the campaign
and decided that I needed to really think
about my direction of what I was doing with
my life.
So I went off to Africa, and really just to
rest.
Immediately on landing in South Africa, I
went to a township to -- really, I was interested
in the country, in the culture, and I noticed
that on really every corner, there was a funeral
or a graveyard.
And I just felt something was amiss.
And on asking the local people, they told
me it was AIDS.
It was HIV, and the stigma that surrounded
it was so powerful that people weren't even
admitting that their family members had died
of AIDS.
And at that moment, it struck me, "Well, why
can't we do here in Africa what we are doing
in Romania?
In such an innovative way of tapping into
the private sector and using the built-in
resources and infrastructure in that country
to deliver these much-needed messages about
stigma and discrimination and condom use in
a much more effective way.
And not only do that, but to bring these extra
resources to the issue.
To bring Hollywood, to bring corporations,
to get corporate money, and to really expand
on what is already happening in that country.”
So back in Romania, I returned very quickly,
very excited, very, very excited that I had
sort of got this vision of what I wanted to
do.
And I was actually very excited with the thought
that I might be able to leave the private
sector and do something worthwhile with my
life.
So, on arriving back to Romania, we -- a couple
of things that we did were -- and these are
the "Love Police.”
The Love Police go down to the Black Sea Coast,
and arrest people on the beach who are not
carrying condoms.
And with their ticket, they get a condom.
So we have these Love Police all over Romania,
arresting people.
Again, a different innovative way of delivering
this message. So, PSI.
So obviously, I found out then from my friend
and mentor, Michael Holscher, that PSI was
not just in Romania -- that PSI was all over
the world -- actually in 40 countries.
And he told me that PSI was a very successful,
global health organization that predominantly
focused on getting government funding.
And perhaps PSI would be open to hearing about
this idea of bringing extra resources.
Now PSI all started with this.
This one condom.
And a couple of trucks.
And the trucks that you see here were actually
in Bangladesh.
40 years ago when PSI started, this is how
these condoms were distributed.
If you think about it, 40 years ago, even
to us, condoms were scarce.
It was a taboo subject.
So take a country like Bangladesh, where the
stigma and the cultural situation in the country
was even worse.
One of our founders felt that this is what
needed to happen, that we needed to bring
vital health care, health services, health
products to people who really need them the
most.
So this was all started in Bangladesh from
the back of a truck.
So PSI's mission, as I said, is really to
save lives.
I like to joke that "PSI is one of the most
effective and largest health organizations
in the world that nobody has ever heard of.”
You hear about CARE.
You hear about Save the Children.
You hear about UNICEF.
Size relation, we're actually very similar.
And our focus -- and the focus there in Romania
13 years ago, or 12 years ago, when I was
there -- was to improve the life, people's
lives and health, all over the world, and
really to have grassroots, measurable results
in all of the countries.
So when I joined PSI ten years ago to start
YouthAIDS, we had 40 country programs.
And now, we're in 65 countries around the
world, reaching almost a billion people with
these life-saving health products and services.
I would like to say that I can take credit
for that, but I really can't.
It's a group of extraordinary people, about
8,000 people worldwide who every day make
it their mission to develop these winning,
creative solutions to deliver this much-needed
health care services and products to these
people.
And some of these people you can see here
in these images.
We go into deepest, darkest Africa, to Asia,
to all these different places in the world
that are very hard to reach.
And you must imagine, for instance, that a
sixth of the world does not have access to
drinking water.
Now, I was privy to the most amazing lunch
ever today in Google -- which I can not believe
you get every day and every night.
All those free drinks and free food.
But this is a very different situation around
the world, obviously.
And we need to find ways to reach people in
very rural and urban areas with these life-saving
messages and behavior change techniques to
have them realize why themselves and their
families are getting sick from purely preventible
diseases.
And some of these diseases are malaria, HIV,
tuberculosis, pneumonia, reproductive health,
women giving birth to children under trees,
or having unsafe abortions -- really do account
for hundreds of millions of lives every year.
So these are some of the countries that we're
in.
We really do span across the whole world.
We're in 65 countries across five continents.
Most of these countries I've actually been
to now -- which was actually one of my real
objectives is to go and learn about the situation
all over the world, about how people are living
and how they are finding access to this health
care.
Now, just to explain my internal challenge
a little bit, because when I came to PSI with
this very fancy idea of reaching out to Hollywood
and the corporate world, PSI was -- and still
is -- a decentralized organization.
So you have to imagine that there's many companies
all over the world with CEOs heading up those
local programs.
And they really need a local identity, because
they work locally with the government.
They have local resources.
They fill a very critical gap between what
the government is doing and what the private
sector is doing.
So a highly effective organization already,
but had never told the story of themselves.
Again, one of the most highly successful health
organizations in the world, but nobody knows.
So my job was to come in and, first of all,
convince PSI that this is something that I
should be doing.
And again, PSI had very -- oops, PSI had very
little brand identity and no equity in the
PSI brand.
And, quite frankly, the programs themselves
weren't really interested in this YouthAIDS
idea.
So it was very much a case of having to prove
myself and having to prove this idea of YouthAIDS.
So my mission was to take this idea that I
had drummed up in the slums of South Africa,
and try to build it into a global brand.
And I found myself in an office in Washington
really not knowing anybody or really having
any connections.
So my first job was to reach out to some of
the champions that I have known over my career
to try to make this work.
And my first call was to MTV, who I had worked
with in Eastern Europe.
So I say that, "I am on a mission to find
champions.”
And my mission was to find these champions,
to gain corporate support, to build vital
partnerships, to bring the media to put a
public face to what PSI is doing, and to recruit
celebrity ambassadors, which was a whole journey
all on its own.
So what I want to do now is -- rather than
me talk -- I always feel that it's much better
to show videos.
>> 15 to 24.
>> I love hip hop.
>> Beck.
>> Curty Chestnut.
>> People have sex.
I have sex.
You guys have sex.
>> Justin Timberland.
>> Get tested to know your HIV status.
>> [drums]
>> Alicia Keys.
>> There's no cure, but there's a way for
you to have.
>> Wyclef Jean.
This is Wyclef Jean.
>> YouthAIDS is about kids coming together
for kids. People.
>> [drums]
>> YouthAIDS is a global HIV prevention initiative
working in 70 countries to educate young people
about HIV and AIDS.
[drums]
Through partnership with leading global brands
already popular with youth as well as their
favorite celebrities, YouthAIDS is spreading
the word.
YouthAIDS partnered with Sanrio and Macy Gray
to promote a T-shirt featuring Hello Kitty.
Macy Gray: Hey, this is Macy Gray, and I am
angry because AIDS takes the life of one child
every minute.
>> One hundred percent of the proceeds benefited
YouthAIDS programs.
>> Five million further infections every single
year.
>> Kristin Davis also joined the campaigns
which sold thousands of T-shirts for YouthAIDS.
>> Missy Elliot partnered with Levi's and
YouthAIDS to create a one-of-a-kind jean jacket
that was sold on World AIDS Day 2002.
>> Magic Johnson promoted the Sketchers duffle
bag branded with YouthAIDS.
>> Magic Johnson Foundation, YouthAIDS, and
Sketchers to help save lives.
>> I take risks every day, but this is one
risk I won't take.
>> It has proven that messages delivered by
leading artists resonate effectively with
kids ages 15 to 24.
>> I love hip hop.
>> Beck.
>> Curty Chestnut.
>> People have sex.
I have sex.
You guys have sex.
>> Justin Timberlake.
>> Get tested to know your HIV status.
>> Alicia Keys.
>> There's no cure but there's a way for you
to have.
>> Wyclef Jean.
This is Wyclef Jean.
YouthAIDS is about kids coming together for
kids, people coming together for people to
protect and educate all of our kids against
HIV.
>> Timberland's announcement that he plans
to produce an update on the 1985 classic,
"We Are The World."
>> Timberland.
I'm going to do the same thing that Quincy
did back 20 years ago, two decades ago.
>> Quincy Jones, 6,000 kids become infected
every day.
>> Dave Matthews.
Nothing quite as good as an orgasm.
That's for sure. That's for sure.
But, you know, nothing quite as bad as dying
prematurely either.
So protect yourself.
>> And Michelle Branch have endorsed YouthAIDS
and their corporate sponsors.
These unprecedented celebrity and corporate
partnerships enable YouthAIDS to deliver a
clear message that is making an impact around
the world.
>> [drums]
>> Use your prophylactic, man!
>> [strumming a guitar] [singing] "I'm going
to tell you children one thing.
Trust me. You should use your condom."
Kate Roberts: Okay. So sorry I'm going to
have to flip back to the presentation here.
So what you see there is after a couple of
years.
I have to say -- San Francisco means something
for me, because I remember the very early
years of not having a lot of resources to
do this.
I actually took a Greyhound Bus from San Francisco
to LA, because we just literally did not have
any money to get me -- to fly me around chasing
these partnerships.
Sorry. So that was where we were in the beginning.
And the -- Oh, okay.
Does anybody know how to get this back? I'm
so sorry.
[long pause]
Okay. Perfect. Thank you. Sorry.
One thing I have never learned is how to do
these things properly.
So again, to get back to where we were.
The first real project that launched us into
orbit with our brand was this unprecedented
partnership between MTV Networks International,
the Gates Foundation, Paul Allen, and Levi's.
And what it was, was a global partnership
and concert series that was made into a 90-minute
documentary and aired in 170 countries around
the world.
And YouthAIDS and PSI were the driving force
behind the messaging.
We engaged the talent behind it, we worked
with the talent to develop various PSA's,
and we aired it in all the countries that
MTV were not in.
And I would say that this was the platform
really that helped us to launch YouthAIDS
and to get others involved.
You know, one of the challenges I think of
the developing world is, there are so many
worthy causes.
And you really have to find a way to get your
cause out there and cut through the clutter
of everything that's going on.
Back then, ten years ago, was a very different
landscape than what it is right now with everything
that we have going on online.
And the power then was really through multimedia,
television, radio, and on the ground.
And this was the most remarkable experience
of shipping Pea Diddy and Alicia Keys and
Usher and various stars to South Africa where
I had originally had the idea of YouthAIDS.
So one very touching moment was taking Alicia
to a clinic where all the women in the clinic
were just about to give birth, and they were
all HIV positive.
There was 25 beautiful African ladies, and
they had heard that Alicia was coming to speak
to them about this issue.
And they had heard about two weeks before.
And when we walked in, they were lined up
-- the most beautiful women -- and they burst
into her song, "Fallin'.”
It was when she had just -- she was just becoming
famous for that song, and they had been rehearsing
it over the two weeks so that they could give
her a welcome.
But for me, that was a very touching moment,
because it is in the townships of South Africa
was where it had all started.
So cause-marketing, back then, was relatively
new.
And I think the power of the MTV "Staying
Alive" project really helped us to bring in
these various companies.
To give you an example of one of them, Kiehl's,
which is a brand which I'm sure we all use
and know.
Kiehl's had never spent a dollar on doing
any form of advertising, and they had a product
that was on their shelves that was not selling.
And we approached them to do a product for
YouthAIDS.
And they decided to use this product that
wasn't doing well.
And they re-branded it, put the YouthAIDS
logo on it.
And it literally flew off the shelves, and
in two weeks, they had cleared their entire
stock.
So, on forming these partnerships, it's about
finding win-win solutions, and finding win-win
strategies that are really going to help to
sustain these programs.
And I was on a personal journey of finding
a company -- one company -- that would really
embrace this issue, and put all their resources
behind it and make it part of their brand,
make it part of their network.
So whereas these projects had been great learning
experience, you know, they'd raised a couple
million dollars, I really wanted to find one
brand that could do that.
And this was the company.
The background behind ALDO Shoes is that,
they had been giving silently to AIDS causes
since the beginning of the pandemic.
And the general manager was sitting on a plane
one day, and he opened US Weekly, one of the
tabloids.
And in the tabloid, he found a picture of
Kristin Davis from Sex and the City wearing
the Hello Kitty YouthAIDS T-shirt.
And he thought to himself, "Maybe it's time
for us to be more visible with the work that
we're doing around HIV.”
So he decided to put a call into us when he
arrived back in Canada, and asked me to come
and meet him and their founder, Mr. Aldo Bensadoun.
And we really just talked about their objectives
of what they wanted to do.
And ultimately, as in any for-profit company,
they wanted to sell more shoes.
And they were very forthright about that,
but they also wanted to show their customers
how much they care about them and about the
potential risks of HIV.
So this was the program that was borne out
of that conversation.
And then, about a year later, we went live
with "See No Evil, Hear No Evil, Speak No
Evil," which literally you could see on billboards,
on buses, in advertisements, in magazines.
And what we did with them is, we leveraged
their marketing spend.
They obviously had marketing power with the
dollars that they would buy pages in magazines
or billboards.
And we managed together to double that marketing
space that they were buying to support this
campaign.
This campaign ran in about 25 countries -- to
be honest it's still running in 25 countries.
And it created about 1.5 billion media editorial
impressions.
And that was outside of their advertising.
That was the number of people who wrote about
it or if it was online.
And it's raised about $4 million now that
goes towards our programs.
So for me, this was the turning point of the
YouthAIDS brand, of really finding this corporate
partner to do this.
And there are many stories surrounding how
we got about 40 A-list celebrities to be part
of this campaign.
>> Thousand people dying every day.
>> [rock music]
>> The disease is so real. It's so ________
>> 40 million people have already died of
HIV-AIDS-related causes, an estimated almost
40 million are currently living with HIV.
>> Millions of young people who aren't educated.
>> Obviously it's not a black issue or a gay
issue.
It's a world issue.
>> Young people are a very important part
of ______
>> They make up a large percentage of employees
at the organization.
They're a large percentage of our customers.
We felt a moral obligation to speak out to
them.
We decided to get together with YouthAIDS
and ________ a very compelling message "Hear
No Evil, Speak No Evil, See No Evil."
>> It's about changing the course of history.
It's about changing the world.
It's about social justice.
It's about empowering people to reproductive
health in saving their lives.
>> When we first decided this was going to
be a celebrity-driven campaign -- it was very
recently -- and I really didn't think that
we were going to be able to pull it off -- but
everybody we asked jumped on board, and it's
just been absolutely amazing.
>> I like this campaign for so many reasons.
I mean, first of all, Peter was shooting.
He's someone I've known for years, and he's
a great photographer.
>> To have celebrities there, I thought was
great, because to have people who are known,
agree to put a tape on their eyes.
I mean, that is an amazing thing.
To be covered with a tape
>> You pay the price, you know, like five
dollars to buy two of them.
Actually save a life.
>> These empowerment tags are really cool,
you see?
It's also a reminder that nobody should take
this for granted.
>> So when you buy your empowerment tag, not
only do you contribute five dollars towards
educating and protecting a young person for
a entire year, you make a commitment about
your own participation in the process of awareness
and prevention.
>> I spent ten dollars on two pairs of dog
tags.
How could you go wrong with that?
I mean, God can only bless you.
>> There's no vaccine in sight.
There's no cure in sight.
So really, all we have is prevention.
>> If I could give advice to a young person,
I would say, "Get Tested."
>> And take charge of your life and make smart
decisions with your life.
>> Abstain, use a condom.
It's pretty simple.
>> Prevention is power.
That is our power.
It's so simple when you have the facts.
>> Yo! If you want to learn more information,
>> Go to www.YouthAIDS
>> YouthAIDS
>> YouthAIDS/ALDO
>> www.YouthAIDS/ALDO.org
>> Check it out.
Kate Roberts: Okay, now I actually have a
lot more presentation to do, but I am very
conscious of the time.
And I do like some form of interaction, and
would love any questions that you might have
up until this point.
[pause] Yes.
>> Seems like there's tension between the
company wanting to make money and you wanting
to make money for the cause?
How do you negotiate to figure out what percentage
they're going to get or, you know, what's
fair, and how public do you make that known?
Kate Roberts: Again, I think it's about a
win-win strategy and because we're being protective
over our brand.
You know, we have a brand too, just as ALDO
Shoes does.
And so, it's almost like a licensing deal.
You have to negotiate up front what your boundaries
are and how much you want to raise.
And so, again, you have to have a win-win.
Is that me that's making that noise?
You have to have a win-win.
So you go in and you have to have an honest,
trusting relationship from the beginning that
you're not going to get exploited.
And I think that the public has become more
savvy now, and they can see through campaigns.
So it has to be credible, and it has to be
-- I'm backing away from the microphone.
It has to be credible, and it has to be a
meaty campaign for the consumers to even want
to buy into it now.
That's a really great question, though.
That's a really great question.
Any other questions up until now? Yes.
>> Where's the best practices that you apply
to for-profit and nonprofit worlds?
And then what are the sort of nuances that
you saw like.
Kate Roberts: Mm-hmm. That's a really great
question.
I have to tell you that I don't do anything
differently now than I used to do in the for-profit
world.
And everything I learned doing marketing for
Saatchi & Saatchi, I apply to this.
I think that my experience building brands
before has helped me to build this brand.
And I think the thing that's helped me the
most to build this brand is two things.
One, having a very credible and successful
health organization behind the brand of PSI.
I don't think this would have been possible
without having that organization behind the
brand, because all the money that's raised
goes to PSI's programs to help them with sustainability
and to build more resources.
And secondly, it's passion.
It's just pure passion.
I really, really believe in the organization
and what we're doing.
And I -- you know, when you travel to the
countries and you see for yourself what's
going on, you can't help but have that passion
for what you're doing.
And so, I think that's universal.
You really need to find the passion in your
life and apply it to what you're doing.
We were just talking over lunch about people
who go into work and just do a job to earn
money.
I can't possibly imagine being that person
or not having something greater than myself
to work towards.
But for-profit techniques work for nonprofits.
And I actually think that there are not enough
for-profit people in the nonprofit world -- think
I just lost the presentation -- in the nonprofit
world doing the work that needs to be done
and finding these innovative ways to, again,
cut through the clutter and present your brand
-- to form these partnerships.
Any other questions before we go back? Oh.
Okay.
All right, to quickly go through again.
So another question might be, Well, how do
you sustain, How do you sustain these programs,
you know?
How do you become the core of a company's
brand, and How do you keep these going? How
do you keep it interesting, and also, How
do you bring different corporations into the
mix?
And this is just another example of an organization,
H&M, we all know it.
They've got 1300 stores worldwide.
They believed in the cause themselves, and
this is actually recently run where they just
use their platform internally to develop a
varied range of clothing that we managed to
get Rihanna to be the face of.
And it raised millions of dollars.
And we're just about to launch a health center
in Haiti and Russia with the proceeds.
Again, I referred before about, it's about
finding champions.
There's a number of champions sitting here
with me today.
But these are some of the champions that I've
seen around the world who have really helped
to save lives.
Archbishop Desmond Tutu was the first man
of the church to come forward and talk about
the importance of correct and consistent condom
use.
A big risk.
The church is a powerful medium, and he was
the champion.
A lady here in the slums of India in the purple
sari was given a death sentence by her doctor
when she found out that she was HIV positive.
Her doctor literally told her that she would
die very soon.
And she decided to become a peer educator.
I think we've lost sound.
She decided to become a peer educator.
And before she died, she actually saved hundreds
of thousands of lives by speaking out in a
difficult community with so much prejudice
against people living with HIV.
And she was able to use her power.
So she's a champion.
The Global Fund, the Gates organization, the
government -- they're all champions.
And this is a picture of Michael Holscher,
who originally approached me to do this.
And so, for me, he's a champion.
And I think that, that's really my point -- that
everybody has it in them, and everybody can
be a champion.
These are some of our Celebrity Ambassadors.
We try to find culturally relevant ways to
work with different people from different
backgrounds to get different messages out.
And these are just some of the people.
Miss Universe, Bono, Ashley Judd, Juanas,
and this gentleman who is our ambassador.
His name is Akshay Kumar in India, because
people are going to relate to people in their
own countries.
We also in India worked with Shahrukh Khan,
Shamit Hassan, and that's really what we do
all over the world by social mobilization
and tapping into the cultures.
We've made a number of films.
We've made five documentaries now that have
aired all over the world.
I would encourage you to look and watch these
films.
The National Geographic one was following
Ashley and various Bollywood stars around
India.
I'm not going to do the video thing again.
I can't stand it.
So you might ask yourself how effective YouthAIDS
is.
Well, we've raised almost $20 million in cash.
And probably hundreds of millions of dollars
worth of resources.
The MTV project alone was $90 million worth
of media.
And for me, it's all about partnership.
Because we don't want to reinvent the wheel.
We want to tap into the built-in infrastructure
that exists in the world.
And we're really looking to form those effective
partnerships. Okay.
So, in ending, I'm going to show you one last
video.
Ashley Judd: Good morning.
I am Ashley Judd, and I am the Global Ambassador
for YouthAIDS.
My first trip as YouthAIDS Global Ambassador
was designed around the International AIDS
Conference, which at that time was being held
in Bangkok, Thailand.
Here we are.
I don't know that much about Cambodia.
I left My Lonely Planet to work at home.
But in a way I'm glad, because I think it's
really interesting to come to a place like
this eyes wide open just ready to learn.
I will let them show me what they are about,
rather than come in with any preconceived
notions whatsoever.
And so, the journey begins.
Ashley Judd: We started by visiting a wonderful,
wonderful hospital/hospice, that provides
end-of-life care for the people who've really
been ravished by opportunistic infections
and that are really I think very end of their,
you know, losing battles with HIV/AIDS.
We arrived at a pagoda, which is what they
call their temples, and went inside.
Then the monks entered.
[chanting]
Ashley Judd: It is an enormous pleasure to
sit and have people pray for you.
It's so totally rocked.
So that was all done and we adjourned outside.
I met the Watt grannies.
A Watt granny is a Buddhist woman who takes
on the assignment of caring for at-risk and
vulnerable children.
It was about the most beautiful collection
of women I've ever seen in my life.
They were awesome.
>> Tell them I'll come back and bring my handsome
husband.
>> [speaking in a foreign language]
>> [Laughter]
Ashley Judd: I held some beautiful babies.
Oh man, beautiful babies.
The hardest things were at night in my hotel
room by myself thinking about the people I
met and thinking about this beautiful child
named Osweileia, and just knowing that they
are still in their circumstances.
You know, vulnerable and at-risk is very difficult.
And I was a part of this afternoon was peer
education.
So a sex worker who is dynamic and has an
outgoing personality will be asked to help
educate her peers about HIV, how the virus
is transmitted, and about condoms -- both
male condoms and female condoms -- and how
to insist that your clients use a condom,
and how to safely get out of the situation
if the client refuses.
>> [speaking in a foreign language]
>> [Clapping]
Ashley Judd: Thailand was perfect, because
it's the exact opposite.
We were new in Thailand.
We were just getting started.
And one of the interesting things that we
were able to do was be involved with the government
at the very highest level right away.
Ashley Judd: And the prime minister was gracious
enough during his very busy schedule to give
us not only an audience but a very ample one.
Ashley Judd: We went to an orphanage, and
it's very hard core.
I mean, I've cried more than once over being
in that place.
It's just not right.
It is not right to have to talk to children
so young about such adult issues.
But I can't help the fact that they're there.
And there are a lot of programs and a lot
of government activities directed at preventing
those children from being on the street in
the first place.
However, some are already there.
So we have to reach out to the ones who are
there, identify them, and help them on a consistent
and sustained basis so that they do not become
HIV positive.
That's what this is about.
And seeing store front after store front after
store front after store front of these bars
and karaoke establishments.
I mean, how can I describe what it's like
to go to a brothel?
Nothing prepares you.
Absolutely nothing prepares you.
The women in the brothels and the bars and
the karaoke establishments knew a lot about
HIV/AIDS.
And I would say that a lot of that was a credit
to PSI YouthAIDS programs.
The first group of sex workers with whom I
visited were all HIV positive, and they were
still working in commercial sex.
It's been the journey of a lifetime and a
trip I've been waiting my entire life to take.
Ashley Judd: There's absolutely hope, because
PSI YouthAIDS programs work.
They absolutely 100 percent work.
Being associated with HIV/AIDS associates
you with compassion, with hope.
And what company doesn't want to be associated
with that?
And the more creative people are, the more
broad a population, the messages can reach.
Kate Roberts: So that really shows the work
that we do on the ground.
And we've taken our champions and ambassadors
many different times to see these programs
now.
And it doesn't matter personally how many
times I go to the field and I see the work
that we're doing.
I remain so passionate about what we do and
how we do it.
And the commercial approach that we take.
And you know, I'm on the brand-building side
of it, but doing journeys like this really
helps me to stay motivated and current and
creative, which I think is the most important
thing in doing the work that I do.
So I don't know whether you've got any more
questions?
[pause]
Well, thank you very much.
Thank you. Really appreciate it.
>> [Clapping]